this is the final day of Black History
Month did you know this February 28th
feel sorry for the people that have
birthday on February 29th this morning
we have a story about Unity the black
and Jewish communities in America work
closely together for decades in the
fight for civil rights and then they
drew apart since then despite moments of
collaboration the relationship you could
say remains quite complex now there is a
growing effort in Detroit to bring these
groups closer together so Adriana Diaz
went to the Motor City to meet two
friends who saw a gap in understanding
as an opportunity to build a bridge
across their cultures
for longtime friends Brandon Colvin and
Jacob Smith it's always a good time for
game time
[Applause]
who's got better game
oh friend is four years older than me so
here's what I'll say about that I don't
like to play directly against Jacob
because you've got a little bit too much
energy so when we're on the same team it
works well together they work really
well for five years they've collaborated
on sold out dinners that bring together
the black and Jewish communities to
promote one thing trust when you have
those organic social collisions so to
speak
I look at you a little differently I
have a greater capacity to empathize
Smith is Jewish and from Detroit suburbs
Colvin grew up Christian in Montgomery
Alabama on the next plane State piece to
the Earthman they met more than a decade
ago in Detroit's startup scene and
bonded over a love of music I wonder why
I'm feeling guilty with my people say
the chosen
including this song they recorded
together
and a love of their communities Branham
started bringing me into spaces
predominantly black spaces there's kind
of a standoffish Nest that you can
sometimes feel as a white person coming
into the city just being honest in my
experience and what Brandon allowed for
me was to step into certain spaces and
had just the most incredible experiences
Jacob has been a Gateway in a doorway
into Jewish culture that I had never
experienced I've been to Passover I
didn't realize that I could have this
type of Brotherhood across another
culture until I met Jacob I think he
liked that
we met at a hundred-year-old former
synagogue turned black church so this
building is the intersection between
Detroit's Jewish community and black
community right absolutely it's history
mirrors the city story
yeah
after many black Americans moved North
to Detroit during the Great Migration of
the 20th century discriminatory housing
laws led to overcrowding many white
residents including white Jews were able
to move to the suburbs perpetuating a
segregation that persists today even
though our cultures are different in a
lot of ways we both have a history that
involves oppression for Jewish people
there's kind of this unique balance of
in today's day and age
being perceived with white skin I can
tuck in my Star of David necklace to go
into a job interview while at the same
time having a very real lived experience
with Rising anti-Semitism you can
tucking in his star David I obviously am
black everywhere I go but what I think I
really appreciate is that we see people
who are able to take advantage of
certain privileges ensure that they are
leveraging those privileges for the
benefit of other people the community is
famously joined forces during parts of
the Civil Rights Movement but in recent
years the relationship between the
groups has been in the spotlight for a
different reason Kyrie Irving finally
apologized for his social media post
promoting an anti-semitic movie I could
say anti-semitic things and Adidas can't
drop me Adidas did drop Kanye West after
that remark when we have these divisive
comments that get made
I think they're really missing the space
to sort of reach over the aisle to join
hands and sort of be together and on the
same page can everybody hear me okay
Colvin and Smith held their latest
cross-cultural dinner what they call the
Coalition series at the Detroit
Historical Museum
a Shabbat meal catered by a local black
Chef I think we all have something we
can learn from each other I didn't know
that they had similar struggles to what
we had Shane Sperling has been attending
Smith and colvin's events for years his
mother is white and Jewish and his
father is black there's situations where
the Jews were not good to black people
black people not good to Jews but it
makes me proud just as a black Jew to
know that there are people that want to
know and want to have a conversation
there's this horrible stereotype of like
comparing oppressions right like how do
you deal with that if we get into the
sort of Oppression Olympics sort of
conversation it's almost a non-starter
as far as I'm concerned yeah it's
counterproductive I think real
conversation should be what can these
two communities come up with given their
shared understanding of what it is like
to achieve in spider achieving progress
to together
for CBS mornings Adriana Diaz Detroit
Adriana I like that I like that of
Christian Olympics you can't say my pain
is bigger than your pain because the
pain hurts no point in outsuffering each
other counterproductive I like how he
started off he said we create these
organic social collisions yes how often
do we do that you know in our own lives
or should we do it more yeah yeah no
it's really interesting you know there's
a kind of a simple story about the Jews
and the black community with you know
Martin Luther King marching with rabbis
three Jews killed in Mississippi
Mississippi Burning case and you think
there's this history of just pure
togetherness but it's taken twists and
turns right so it's much more complex
and I think Adriana really did a good
job getting at that really good job yeah
nicely done yeah all right